hey et family it's your girl leslie
grace and you are on the video set of my
new song fatiga
[Music]
we're here in this beautiful sort of
like speakeasy bar yes can you walk us
through like the narrative of the video
and why are we here in the roaring 20s
yes i think is a very romantic um and
sultry
song i knew that the song made me feel
like i was in another time it felt
really classic and i've already done the
60s in the past people used to love me
so i was like 20s we're in the roaring
20s why not and then jorge camarena our
director sent in this incredible concept
which was to take
us from a 1920s dance party where we
meet and
ian and i and we we kind of go into this
dance face-off like wow yeah i kind of
challenge him to show me what he's got
in the middle of the dance floor and
then we begin to dance
and through that dance we start to have
flashbacks and we go into these
different stages of these two people's
relationships and i just off the top of
my head thought about this scene from um
gatsby where
leo walks in he's like he's like waiting
in the rain for the love interest i
remember looking at this and being like
oh leo's so awesome man like so is that
who you're channeling today a little bit
yeah i'm doing a little leo yeah a
little bit leslie's always talking about
i'm her i'm her leo so
i try to tap into my guide today
[Music]
shout out santo domingo shout out
chicago
i have to imagine that was inspired by
your real life yes yes yes actually our
my co-writers who are all female uh maya
and luciana they wanted to include some
things that were like very personal and
they came up with that line santo
domingo and and the little shout out to
chicago and knew that i would like fall
in love with it and we built the song
from there and that's why
i also
am so excited that i get to share it
with you know the person that
you know is part of the inspiration of
it also yeah i'm from chicago so i hear
chicago and something and i'm like
this is important
i'm like this is an important song yes
it's different yeah so i knew it was on
the radar i knew it was like in the
scope and you know she had mentioned
that um you know i was inspiration for
some of the things i was just super
honored as as a guy
[Music]
i have to tell you i was going through
the lyrics and i had to fan myself it's
it's a sexy leslie grace song it's
monkey right is this the sexiest song
you think you've ever done ooh
it's in there it's a
provocative yes but in the smooth sexy
smoky sonically in that world so it's
it's a different angle of of that that i
haven't been been in yet look he says
she served us what we want i love it
[Music]
how intense is the dancing in this video
and what's the training been like oh man
it's it's intense it was very new for
the both of us ian's never danced you
know bachata before and definitely he's
not even danced like all of his dancing
that he's known for and he's so
incredible at is usually as a soloist
and so for us to come together um under
very
high stakes
in a week was you know it was a little
bit of pressure yeah one week to learn
everything yeah one one week i told
leslie right away as soon as i knew that
there was pachata in this i was like i'm
out
i'm out of this this is way beyond like
just cause i can dance does not mean i
can do everything it was a big learning
curve for me
um to even just dance with a partner it
was cool because it gave us almost
another new layer to our whole
relationship really yeah
[Music]
i see this huge smile on your face yeah
working with your man in real life
working with him now on screen what has
that been like it's so beautiful it's
such a blessing i mean i think the most
beautiful part of our connection is that
we both have incredible mutual respect
for what each of us does individually
and when we get to do it together um
it's just such a joy to be able to work
with you know with with someone that you
love that is equally as great
um at what they do and then being able
to to join forces and that it's really
really special being on camera with her
is is like as a totally different
experience yesterday we there's like
some scenes that are supposed to be like
arguing and stuff and we like don't have
like heated like yelling arguments like
that like all of our like discussions
are just discussions yes you know level
headaches yeah
which is a blessing in my life it was
difficult especially looking at her
while being like that mad i was like oh
my god lizzie's parents are going to
kill me no
what is it about her that is just so
special to you like i wish that
everybody could get to experience
leslie's presence and their life truly
honestly because from the moment that i
met her and ever started talking to her
she just carries herself with such grace
that it always just um brings like a
calming mood over the room over people
that's like really the greatest part
about getting to spend my time with her
is that i just get to see not only that
she gives that to me but also to every
single person
at the exact same level and volume so
that's really well now you got me
watering up and you got leslie watering
up
[Music]
thanks for hanging out with me et family
and next time i see you i want to see
you dance
[Music]